[Música]
la textura del servicio
como un valor para el crecimiento
que podemos identificar como de
servicios
donde vemos un servicio donde vemos una
actitud y qué tiene que ver la actitud
visión para el crecimiento
todos en la vida ofrecemos un servicio
todos en la vida tomamos la vida cada
día con una actitud
y yo les pregunto a ustedes
que quieren ser cuando sean grandes lo
han pensado alguna vez se les ha dicho a
sus padres ya comenzaron las órbitas por
allí verdad
qué quieres ser cuando seas grande mi
hijito
que quiero hacer cuando sea grande
yo les pregunto
qué huella quieren dejar ustedes con lo
que deciden pero sobre todo con la
actitud con la que ustedes se van a
dirigir siempre cada día en todo momento
con las personas que están y que viven a
su alrededor
y qué pasa cuando ustedes ofrecen un
servicio
actitudes hay miles hay positivas hay
negativas y actitudes son las que van a
definir y las que van a hacer una gran
diferencia
entonces por eso el día de hoy estamos
hablando sobre la actitud de servicio
porque eso va a ser lo que va a permitir
en todo momento
ser y hacer esa diferencia para eso
tenemos que ser
e indiscutiblemente tenemos que hablar
de la tecnología de la innovación qué
maravillosa es la tecnología y ve el día
con tantos avances con tantos beneficios
que nos da que hay veces confundimos y
dejamos que la tecnología sustituya ese
valor tan grande y tan preciado que es
la actitud de servicio ese hablar entre
tú y yo es comunicarnos ese llevarnos
esa convivencia
hoy algo que me gustaría que se quede y
que les quede muy claro
y que puedan aplicar en su vida es la
actitud del servicio con la posibilidad
de disfrutarla de llevarla a cabo de
compartirla aprovechando toda esa
innovación tecnológica que tenemos hoy
en nuestras manos que nos permite
aligerar muchas actividades muchas
responsible responsabilidades y sobre
todo nos permite tener más tiempo para
tener una convivencia de valor una
convivencia con valores que van
adjudicados y que podemos aplicar en
nuestro día a día y que son los que van
a hacer la diferencia
podremos estar de acuerdo
en lo que piensas pero defenderé hasta
la muerte tu derecho a expresar lo y eso
es algo que nos da la pauta que
encierran muchos valores y que
determinan la actitud de servicio con la
que tú estás compartiendo con los demás
y la actitud del servicio con la que
estás compartiendo con las personas que
están alrededor en el colegio en el
instituto en el trabajo en la familia
entre los cuates también
respetar al demás y respetar sus
decisiones sus palabras sus opiniones es
uno de los principales valores que
engloba esta actitud de servicio de la
que hablamos hoy
cuando tú estás hablando y están todos
en el cotorreo hablando de los jóvenes y
de repente piensas y quieres opinar de
algo importante sobre lo que dando y
estás pidiendo
pero esta otra vez estoy hablando y no
te deja hablar cómo se sienten a poco no
dices
yo te quiero decir algo importante pero
no siempre uno que está acaparando los
demás
y permite se sientan respetados en ese
momento
no verdad
entonces si ustedes han vivido una
experiencia en la que no les han
permitido sexo
y servir o tener una actitud o poder
expresarse sean ustedes anfitriones para
no caer en ese error para no tener esa
actitud negativa porque al final de
cuentas también es un servicio
otros de los valores y tan importantes
es la tolerancia
dicen por ahí que dios nos dio dos oídos
o dos para escuchar y una boca para
hablar y va de la mano con el respeto
pero también tiene que ver con la
tolerancia darse la oportunidad de
escuchar a los demás para poder opinar y
dejar que tu interlocutor
se exprese para que entonces también
tenga el respeto y la tolerancia de
darte tu lugar y entonces tener una
mejor convivencia eso nos ha resultado
una actitud de servicio el amor que les
puedo decir del amor hay varios tipos de
amor
y el amor lo hemos reflejado todos lados
a mí me gustaría compartirles hoy una
teoría que una persona que admiro mucho
me compartió y considero que es muy
importante porque esto
es algo que marca la diferencia también
hay cinco formas de demostrar el amor
la primera es con demostraciones de
afecto tocando me dijeron pero tocando
con respeto
tocando es decir un abrazo y un saludo
una palmada esa es una demostración de
amor en las segundas con palabras hay
personas que son muy hábiles para
expresarse de manera verbal y entonces
expresan su amor con palabras la tercera
es con regalos puede ser que no te diga
que te quiere no te expresión te
demuestre su cariño su amor con un
con palabras o con una demostración de
afecto pero siempre te trae aunque sea
una paleta porque te tiene presente en
el pensamiento
la cuarta forma de demostrar el amor es
con calidad d
tiempo o tiempo de calidad el tiempo que
esté contigo esa persona ya me dice sus
padres o la persona con la que conviven
ustedes dedica el tiempo para compartir
ciertas experiencias juegos pláticas
charlas hasta ver una película juntos
sin interrupciones del celular de la
tablet o de la computadora o del trabajo
o de las juntas y demás
y el último que es el kill la quinta
forma de demostrar el amor
con servicio
como me va a demostrar una persona su
amor con servicio si no me dice que me
quiere si además está más regalado nada
además ni siquiera me da un abrazo
y sobre todo el tiempo por estar conmigo
o siempre a la grada o apurado haciendo
cosas bien estas personas que no te
demuestran el amor con estas primeras
acciones
te demuestra el amor preparándote una
deliciosa comida
o tener toda tu ropa limpia doblada
colocada organizada teniendo tu espacio
limpio dándote un servicio me recuerda
de repente a mi abuelita que siempre
parecía que todo el tiempo nos estaba
regañando a no pero siempre nos tenía
preparado algo tan rico y tan delicioso
y esa era su forma de demostrarnos su
amor porque a ella no le enseñaron a dar
abrazos a decir te quiero o a
demostrarte de otra forma entre su mejor
forma de demostrar el amor era con
servicio cuando tú conoces que hay
personas que de acuerdo a la educación
que han tenido tienen una demostración
de afecto de cariño de amor contigo e
identifica que es una de estas eso
permite que tú puedas tener más
tolerancia más amor una mejor actitud de
respuesta con esa persona una mejor
interacción una mejor comunicación
y sobre todo una excelente relación hoy
día ya ustedes no pueden decir es que no
me quiere porque no me regala nada
pongan atención que hacen por ustedes y
lo más importante ustedes que hacen por
los demás cuál es su forma de demostrar
el amor eso hace y eso va a definir la
actitud de servicio con la que siempre
estén en demostración con los demás
la humildad y la generosidad es algo que
cuando tú estás consciente de tus áreas
de oportunidad y de tus valores
va a hacer que te puedas comunicar mejor
con los demás
se dice que la grandeza de una persona
no se mide por lo que tiene sino por lo
que
y estos son valores muy importantes la
perseverancia por ejemplo
es otro de los valores que están dentro
del servicio de la que hoy día estamos
hablando y la que va a ser que ustedes
cuando nos apliquen van a marcar la
diferencia en donde estén con quien esté
y van a poder dejar una huella positiva
una huella que van a ver reflejadas en
ustedes mismos también
la perseverancia el hecho de tener esa
voluntad de terminar lo que empiezan es
importante puede haber miles y millones
de ideas miles y pueden tener unas ideas
maravillosas pero cuáles son las que van
a tener un impacto las que ustedes
terminen
las que se vean los resultados de las
ideas que ustedes están haciendo y
aplicando y llevando a cabo
solidaridad cuántas cosas hermosas y
cuántas innovaciones y cuánto desarrollo
no ha habido en el mundo gracias a la
solidaridad de personas de estados de
naciones con esta globalización la
solidaridad es algo que ha dado la pauta
a que la tengamos hoy día en el país
y en el mundo por supuesto la honestidad
y la responsabilidad son aquellas que es
simplemente en group and olas con los
demás valores van a hacer que es su
actitud de servicio sea única podrá
haber una empresa puede haber una
familia puede haber una escuela que dé
exactamente el mismo servicio pero la
actitud es lo que va a marcar la
diferencia
tú puedes hacer la diferencia y lograr
lo que te propongas cuando quieras ese
trabajo que tanto anhelas tu actitud de
servicio puede ser lo que te lleve al
éxito
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]